[Music]
wake up early in the morning press play
and let's get it in cause we rocking
with the fighter
[Music]
today you got the fresh cup for yannis
for your girls b-day
uh for giannis that makes sense come on
what'd you do for your girls b-day
because you went sorry fellas can't go
to the gym it's my girl's b
day listen i always go after the fact
what do you mean at night yeah i always
go after like i'll go after this because
did you guys
uh like do a just like a breakfast yeah
yeah then we'll go to dinner tonight and
stuff like that you know where you going
to dinner
or some vegan spot and your girl doesn't
like like like if you surprise her like
if you got a big
no she's like a party we're going to do
something
i'm kind of with her on that yeah you
know yeah you don't like nah it's
awkward awesome yeah you don't seem like
this
how does she uh 32
still young yeah yeah i'm 34 she's 32.
yep does she know you missed the
zoo gym yeah for her
that's a big deal you're losing weight
though you're losing weight yeah i'm
trying man i did i do how much did i do
the other day in the 250 first 250 250
for
10 10. um 250 for 10. okay
i'm trying to get to 3 15. that's three
that's three plates you do 3 15
now like one or two for sure i'm scared
but
i want to do you could do it he he man i
don't know i know
he was so cocky i know he was cocky
because he had that little leg photo
with the little flexion this weekend i
was like okay
you didn't see the chain one did you see
the chains i didn't see the chain you
didn't see what the driver was he just
posted
uh i think it was the other day what
they were i think yeah
bring up that ig where it's raining
where it's raining in uh zoo
he's like where am i where the tear
drops from my quads are making it rain
because it was all rain
we were doing uh pull-ups with the two
or yours mine
is kwazilla huh quad's not included it's
a thick boy summer i keep [ __ ]
telling you oh yeah yeah yeah
that's the one yeah that's raining i
wanted to post i wanted to post mine but
mine's
but i look too i look too scary you're
definitely a riverside
tent it is good yes uh yeah i said
straight up calabasas six
that and i remember i might be playing a
lot of celebrities in calabasas
whiskey pete said are you going to fight
again how dare you whiskey pete
cause i'm getting in shape i can't get
shaved i gotta fight but you're look
you're looking good too oh once you get
that leg sleeve yeah you're gonna be
like dude we've motivated so many
[ __ ] people
really yeah i get messages all the time
for people like yo
thanks for motivating me they'll send
like their uh their progress photos
oh damn yeah what that guy do baby
yeah wow good for them not not i mean i
haven't seen anyone to like
yeah but you know yeah those chains were
[ __ ] tough
he did two chains oh yeah but before
that we went
before that i did 315 for what 12. i did
3 15 for 12. mark you did it for games
he did 315 for 12.
what the [ __ ] i mean and y'all work out
with bradley sometimes huh
every time oh no brad no bradley i do me
and bradley work out together
i've worked our squad monday through
friday usually unless you know some [ __ ]
comes up it's me
chappelle and uh mark harley okay yeah i
mean mark worked that sworn he had a
i was like i don't want to be like do we
have to do this was it oh tough one it
was one of those high knees
oh yeah you know squat jumps and then
burpees
oh and they had a camera guy there mark
looked all sweet
he had like this black headband on us oh
yeah why would you tell me yeah
what was that when he had us do what was
like swings then uh
squad jumps uh
and then pull-ups and then like switch
lunges and [ __ ] like that my heart rate
was yeah
yeah yeah because oh no it was we had to
do a hundred swings
a hundred uh squad drums hundred pounds
or fifty pull-ups yeah
okay so it's just like it's like it's a
circuit it's a circuit but still like
this
it'll get you going it gets you going
look at christian he's the official
member now
firing the kid in the squad welcome man
i don't know if a camera goes on him but
yeah he got this jacket
oh no oh you got the official jacket the
official jacket it's kind of it's not
like hell's angels like you were a
prospect before
by prospect i mean for two days
he's crushing it for us though man yeah
welcome welcome back
to those are booming all the clips are
all him he picks the clips
yeah yeah thank you putting peter to
work the rhode island king over here
who's uh in charge of the camera angles
that'd be chin chin why the hell i look
so
goddamn small on every video yeah okay
i'm not gonna lie
i'm not gonna lie uh a lot of the
comments with the
about the misha tay interview okay they
were all saying that uh
she would body you basically they were
saying that she had like a little bit of
uh weight on it looked like
just by the frame i mean like just by
the way you sit side by side
they did say you kind of had a petite
they said that you had a petite frame
next to her you know what it was
whichever was tight was tight i know
what it is you know what it is you're
170 pounds i'm not a honest
i know what it is you're 170 pounds
soaking wet i'm not
talking about we could bring your scale
again yeah he was 180 thank you
and i'm a little that's still that's a
little weird
i'm on my way though but i just don't
like it misha is not 180.
no you should exactly and we look like
if she got her hands on you
it would be so fun to watch what do you
mean she can [ __ ] grapple something
black belt jiu-jitsu
i'm kind of i gotta reach i gotta reach
dude
uh fighting stuff and she obviously me
and her balls deep in fighting
was it weird for you guys no not at all
i'm super interested because i
i didn't like i mean getting into ufc
more so
recently like in that in that whole
world uh
but i thought it was super [ __ ]
interesting because i i've never heard
you talk about like
your whole fighting experience like your
whole like thoughts on it or anything
like that because
i mean we just talk about [ __ ] guts
[ __ ]
yeah also go ahead no good but
guts oh they said butts i was like yeah
that too oh yeah
no behind the scenes like you didn't
feel like fighting that day you have a
big fight you got like like what i know
thousands of people waiting to see this
main event he's like oh
man [ __ ] this main event and all that so
a lot of people don't understand that
like yeah
yeah people's mental if you don't know
what someone's going to be like oh man
he's
trash today misha is a good one for you
guys because she's a she's been in the
game for a while and she speaks well
she speaks so a lot of fighters don't
speak like that mm-hmm oh really no and
she was you know
the vice president of one championship
yeah so she's on the business side you
know she's a beast she's getting enough
money have you seen that dude that's in
the one championship rouge roosevelt oh
he's talking about it yeah yeah big
[ __ ] yeah
look like me like you yeah he big
[ __ ] if you're on a real stack
of steroids you look
like him that man not on steroids
i know
omar kane rules one more k 3-0 he's 29
okay boy if that ain't me
that's that's definitely not you i know
you're not yet done yeah a few few more
summers at
zoo and then i don't think he's on
steroids just wait for it
i just look at him right here
now here's the thing you never know what
those guys straight from after like
they built he low-key looks like the
baby yeah
so that guy that guy on the left too
that guy's a [ __ ] oh i'm swinging the
guy on the left
and the left is what i'm talking about
oh the guy on the left oh
for sure guy in the left pissing hot
he's gotten the right probably just
african
but but like they so they don't they
don't test in that not like the ufc
why is that they just don't they don't
do like a lot of leagues didn't forever
the
you you the only reason you saw it is so
strict because they wanted to go
mainstream and sell
but it was it was interesting because
you said like i mean that guy's on all
the juice
yes be honest yeah oh look at that you
saw yeah go back to that kick god
damn oh he's a beast you got to see his
business bro he got he got the splits
like
nothing jacked i bet that dick
don't quit i bet you that
i mean that bad baby don't quit
don't quit don't worry
about that that did persevere
i bet you that cameroon sauce
yeah he's a beast man he said oh he's
he talked about steroids in that post
look no i'm now any sort of steroids or
substance enhancement
oh yeah yeah so even after my share took
it with she was pregnant with me she
said no
okay well that sounds pretty sketchy
wait what what
my mom said no yeah oh his mom said no
again maybe he's not bro africans they
differ
we need to get more plates more dates on
it natty or not
he really dives into it i mean that
would be good what would make it
i don't know if he's big enough star for
it but i think for sure
okay but wait trt and roids are
different huh
i'm more uh what's that yeah
trt's like you know like so let's say
you're deficient
in whatever it is vitamin c vitamin d so
if you're deficient in testosterone if
you get to natural levels between 300
and a thousand
which trt will do you're but also that's
not trt
like oh no crg doesn't do that
not i mean unless you're taking mass
amounts of and overuse it for what's
not what it's made for then maybe wait
is either way that boy's thinking
either way that boy jack jack jack jack
look at him is he doing a handstand no
i think he's like swinging himself down
he got he got a cannon down in the back
guys
got my ass on my boy his bodied up we
got that you got some wings too
his body
i would love to see a sex tape with this
man [ __ ] dave portnoy i would love to
see
my boy allen valley [ __ ] i think it's
elaine or something like that
and gonna i think he's like 40.
he's 40 years old i think he's 40 years
old he's sexy look at it look at this
splits bro
let me see where um him against the
mirror the
this no no go down oh yeah oh
ain't he reading the book one yeah study
strong support bounce the regular
stretch and mobility training or to
improve flexibility minimize any loss of
range of motion at any age it's never
too late to start making improvements in
your flexibility
and the sooner you start the sooner
you'll see progress i hate when they do
that just i think
i think he's 40. he's 40. 45. oh [ __ ]
damn 5 11 2 30.
who who's that uh he was in the naked
soldier
he from my camera room what was what was
that og football player
um he's from dallas i think he's from
texas
that fought in uh mma all right party no
no not great oh older guy i know uh he's
republican
oh herschel walker 2021 mental health is
finally a
thing thank god because a lot of people
are struggling out there so many people
are struggling right now
and aren't feeling like their normal
selves even though the world start to
open up
that mental sickness just isn't going
away because you need to talk to
somebody you need to talk somebody who
knows what the hell they're talking
about just don't talk to your friends or
family
talk to real licensed professionals and
that's where better help
comes in man it's online therapy that
offers video
phone even live chat sessions with your
therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
but they also can do that
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy you can start communicating with
your therapist under 48 hours
joins joins joins i don't like men's all
right
join the millions of people who are
seeing what therapy is really about see
if it's for you
because you are your greatest asset this
podcast firing the kids is sponsored by
betterhelp
and you guys get 10 off your first
month at betterhelp.com fighter that's
betterhelphelp.com
fighter tell you what man when it's time
for lunch or dinner especially out of
family for dinner it can be chaotic
but not with freshly it's easy the chef
takes care of all your meals a few
nights a week
takes pressure off you mom dad don't
worry about it man
relax let freshly take the wheel all
right
whether you're trying to get in shape
and eat right freshly can help if you're
on a diet we gotcha
their delicious meals are designed by
nutritious and cooked by chefs
making it easier to eat better all right
freshly offered chef made nutrient
packed delicious meals
delivered fresh to your door no cooking
required my family loves it it's how
your boys losing some weight here
no more eating out no worrying from all
those freaking quick drop off
things we're doing freshly man grocery
shopping cooking can be a pain
especially right now
so with freshly you don't have to go
anymore your meals arrive cooked and
fresh
every week so you can keep your fridge
stocked and skip the trip to the store
ordering is easy
visit freshly.com choose from over 30
delicious satisfying
better for you meals like steak
peppercorns sausage baked penne
their chicken pesto bowl but you can
also choose super healthy stuff if
that's your diet
first you can fit your lifestyle with a
variety of plans and meals to pick from
that work for you and whatever diet
you're on all right or your family size
we got you covered
so you guys can try freshly for just
6.16
per meal stop searching the internet for
healthy food near me every night start
living freshly
your meals are always delivered fresh
never frozen ready to heat and enjoy
in just three minutes right now freshly
is offering you guys 40
off your first two orders when you go to
freshly.com stop stressing about dinner
go to freshly.com
fighter for four dollars off your first
orders freshly.com
slash fighter for four dollars off your
first two orders
i know uh he's a republican oh herschel
walker her
walker what about him that guy's a beast
yeah and he's all natural so that's
awesome we can throw steroid accusations
out there but really
he's we don't know we i don't i don't
know who's natural
herschel walker's natural for sure yeah
so he says he said he just did push-ups
and squats which
all right there's some freaks out there
so yeah
but his body yeah i don't think hersl's
body's like that though no
no but francis is and he's all natural
yeah
yeah it's just that herschel those
genetics
and and francis when i did that uh
hotbox to him he was like dude there's a
million guys walking around the streets
that look just like yeah really
and he fought it like what that's him at
like 50 something
yeah he found strikeforce later in the
game what's a
strikeforce there's just another
strikeforce was a big league they were
like
similar competitors ufc back in the day
and the ufc bought them and took all
their talent and shut them down
but they that's where i mean ronda misha
tate
luke rockhold uh robbie lawler
woodley um uh josh thompson
i mean the list goes on uh they come
from that come from verdum
a ton of people came through yeah so you
can get out of these like
other that was back in the day oh
there's no like there's no league like
that anymore
they were like a direct competitor they
they had one most i think it's still the
most
viewed fight on public access channels
ever
because they were on like straight nbc
or abc that's when kimbo
fought it was like the most viewed fight
of all time okay
so it's nothing yes yeah yeah you're
right so these other organizations are
not like
um in the sense like like with baseball
they have like a
like a triple a no they're not there's
some there's some like we saw in one
chair
they're straight up competitors to the
ufc
no they have few talent that could
compete in ufc but as far as like
depth they don't they just don't have
the depth of the mark ability they just
don't have it
like you know like like tissue is called
cleandex
we refer to every tissue as a kleenex
everyone refers to mma as the ufc
because that's it's like nfl football
ufc mma
like they've taken that market no one
will ever beat them
ever damn i hate to say that yeah know i
i didn't know i didn't know if they
had well they have all the talent they
have all the resources they have all
they have everything to get it done so
these other leagues they might have like
one guy who could hang or
maybe a few like bellator has you know
the top five in every division can
compete in ufc
but we don't know because they might
fight a really good guy in the beat him
but then the rest of
the the guy like their their record's
not great because they're not finding
great competition
ufc you're fighting the best of the best
from day one there's no
gimmies it's like you get to the top
you're the best in the world
hands down damn that's crazy
like ufc is the nfl yeah yeah to say
that
so we say all that to say you don't look
like
[Music]
oh
you said uh the improv had on uh oh
wrestlemania hell yeah your boy logan
paul got standard
by kevin oh man i can't believe that
happened how could he let that happen
bro i didn't know what happened
out of nowhere oh man they were talking
hopefully he's okay
well [ __ ] it looked like it hurt oh man
because you know you want to see that
concussed
well wait what are you talking about so
you kick you kick someone in the belly
natural reaction and then you boom logan
no he was interviewing kept
no he didn't fight god damn it he got
stunned okay okay okay so don't kill me
to move it's a move so so but he it's a
really he didn't get stone cold because
he didn't turn around and do the
stronghold he did he i thought he did it
forward
he did bring that [ __ ] up logan paul i
think his was considered a spear
because a spear yeah we kicked him and
then he uh yeah but he didn't did he
turn around and do it that's a stone
cold when you do reverse style
and do you have jean shorts on i don't
think so
kevin is kevin kevin who uh
i forget his last name wrestlemania
right there yeah
right there look it's stunner
[Laughter]
it's not a weird sport yeah
yeah watch the sneak attack i'll tell
you right now logan paul could have such
a big career in wwe
he could he signed a contract with them
recently yeah but he's like doing these
appearances i'm talking
about like a real career
if you want to tour full-time he'd be
like the miz
i think that's what bad bunny's doing
right now bad guy
yeah they signed those short contracts
oh they got fans in there
[Applause]
he actually looks legit out there bro
that's what i'm saying he hurt
what anyway that's pretty dope so you
watch that damn problem
the hollywood impression the hollywood
improv is open yeah on the fans inside
no no on the patio why but i don't get
it like restaurants we can have half
capacity why doesn't they improv open i
don't know they they had pan listen
on the patio they have all fans outside
it's dirt dope and you know in that like
uh back room we call like the uh
intimate room
yeah they had the lab the lab that's
what it is they had the big ass tv
playing wrestlemania but no one's doing
stand up in the lab nah but they let you
watch tv in there yeah
it's so stupid bro it was all lit it was
like a great you know watching it yeah
i can't just all highlight i appreciate
it but i can't get it right
you wouldn't you wouldn't do that if
like all the comics is just like
they were laughing we were joking uh
would i do what if i was at the end i
would have drive to improv to watch
wrestlemania
no no no let's say you had a set and
then you said oh it was on it and logan
paul's on for sure anyway
since we just had the miz on i'd watch
him okay but i wouldn't be like oh [ __ ]
i gotta see
i don't know who's the main event like
babe
having fun oh they
i'd love to go one live oh to go yeah
i'll go you go hell yeah i'll go
i i can see myself going bro for sure i
know for sure we'll beat the triple tag
team women match they they saw
you talking about the [ __ ] boys dude
the triple b's yeah the triple b's bro
look at that sleeper you have the one
piece on
like like oh yeah big show you have the
one piece but the one strap
[Music]
nope nope i was thinking you would be
like the undertaker guy like
yeah she is a palm bear yeah you're the
paw bear
yeah you're in a like a baggy superman's
warehouse on the side like
no hell no venus no the but we were the
boys we take off oh yeah yeah that'd be
cool that's me that's really cool come
on man
give me something but yeah nah that look
literally we could do that
we're not famous enough no no one uh
this may be a dumb question
inches i don't know where you're going
with this
hold on did you did you measure your
suit like i said is
there anyone from the ufc that comes
with the karate background
oh yeah one okay okay thompson wonder
boy
his name's wanna boy leo machida did
okay so
karate is legit not necessarily
those are like outliers if we're going
to spend your time dedicating mixed
martial arts
don't go into karate don't go into
chronicles
that guy has a karate background yeah
but does he use it
in this yeah his focus oh you can't his
footwork's ridiculous
because of karate he's well yeah he's
won the best to ever do it he has some
of the best stand-up of all time oh
sure does flip stupid [ __ ] he does yeah
hey he's got a legit back tuck he you've
never seen wonder boy fight
monster is he currently still fighting
[ __ ] yeah
he's he's one away from a title shot oh
let's go for the title too he fought
woodley twice
yeah and he's so awkward he's so
athletic
oh [ __ ] his dad owns like the biggest
school and i want to say
south carolina be off on that for karate
for karate so he grew up doing karate oh
[ __ ] but then he grew up doing uh
like the the chuck norris like kick
karate
sparring he's like 120 and 0.
he's crazy like he has crazy knockouts
[ __ ] he's a monster he should train with
us
george saint peter brought him down to
denver to train with us and he [ __ ] up
everybody he [ __ ] everybody so bad
they're like who's next and we're like
i'm good
wait wait because it's awkward style you
couldn't do you was striking
so much more elite than everybody is
that because of karate oh yeah
oh so there's there's things too about
it yeah there it is
does it make the does he make the sound
as well when he fight no
no i mean i've grown up i've always
thought karate was like legit i used to
watch all those
martial arts i love power rangers no if
not just let's say you had a kid and
he's like dad i don't do mma
i'm gonna be like all right let's find
you a karate school you don't do that no
no oh this oh this him right here
boom oh [ __ ] you don't want to [ __ ] with
wonder boy no i don't
i think you should fight he's fighting
uh gilbert burns next and he wins that
he's
burns uh brazilian dude brazilian
jiu-jitsu guy yeah
just oh he just lost oh
okay his kicks are nazos i wonder why
they call him wonder boy
boom god yeah he's just his footwork and
his movement is different
i feel like a nut shot poor johnny
hendricks here
yeah oh
all right i was gonna i was gonna take
karate classes oh that's that that's my
guy right there
oh whitaker right that's what it they
were fighting at 170. so he beat when
remember whitaker was the middleweight
champion for a long time he
starched him and then whitaker went to
middleweight and became world champion
oh got it he was like oh oh
you guys better educate i know right now
and then little machida
i'm loving this world you know because i
grew up like watching like
watch this i get this against my boy
jake ellenberger but
oh wait wait it went was a spinning heel
kick
a spinning heel that was insane hey let
me say it again
you'll see i'm like i don't think you
take karate and be doing all this oh no
i'm not gonna take karate
no if your kids gonna get into mma you
put them in wrestling no i just i'm
about like wrestling that new uh that's
that nunu you gotta learn how to wrestle
no it's been around forever
it's actually the whole sport in history
wrestling yeah
the greeks and they used to pull on
their dicks you never seen the statue
where they're like
upside down once grabbing the just the
root and the balls
that's how they played back then dog
[ __ ] yeah are we talking about why did
they get rid of these
he's the town opponents let's bring him
that dick grab man
do that street fight my dad told me that
graham nuts he was like
yeah bro you getting your ass whooped
you wouldn't bruh what's going on
actually if
[Applause]
so you just went to the improv to watch
the wrestlemania i had a show at the
improv and then i went to uh another
show at don't tell
me oh joe how'd it go our boy uh
white mike still running the donkey yeah
why am i running sales man
bruh yeah it's great bro he had like
like 80 85 people out
no the the one that you did yeah no it
was 135.
i'm sorry and it's outdoor oh yeah on
top of our room i've still made it this
far without doing outdoors
bro come on bro i'm telling you keep
asking me i'm like dude i made it this
far without oh
it's lit i didn't want to cross
bro who else was on the show uh it was
great it was a great lineup
uh kyrie bass brother shabazz yeah
brothers brothers
uh chris cope uh chris cope uh who else
it was
now here's the thing here's the thing i
don't want to talk about anybody the
first time someone ain't [ __ ]
the first comic he went up he's 40 years
old
and he hit on this guy in the audience
and you know when it's like it was black
people there
and it was a black crowd no no it was
like white gay guy
white gay guy hitting on another guy
like a straight guy he's like ooh
stripes
it was like brian cowan
i'm saying so he was hitting on and then
kyrie got up there and he's like man
you hitting on that guy like this sexual
harassment because you ain't like that
you like it four
yeah right and then a black guy just
came he just stood up talk your [ __ ] and
said that
because i guess you know you you do too
much gay at the top like
you're the first colleague it's two
games yeah and then like you know black
now you got some gay
bits but yeah yeah
and i heard he only picked like hot guys
on the lineup and like two ugly girls
he puts hot guys
i hope they refer to me as tight 10.
type 10 you're up yeah
you're doing it
you got this you don't have to wear
daisy dukes though
bruh he loves showing his thighs off i
know kwazil next thing you know
it's gonna be you you don't wear tank
tops do you you wear
like jerseys yeah what's the summer hits
once the thick boy summer officially
hits
yeah when's the first day of summer chin
yeah
june 20th hey you're going to see
brennan on instagram trying to squeeze
oh that was right that's a sunday yeah
oh no
and ends wednesday let's talk about it
and that's depressing
but the thick boy summer officially
launches june 20th we're cool
that's what i should launch all my gear
on sunday yup
summer summer summer summer time
summer nothing better than summertime
time is up ooh summer
you know sorry i wasn't i love this song
i got you know i was that cat and
usually summer for
comics touring like nationwide is a
nightmare you don't want to tour during
the summer but that's
during the regular years yeah now that
things are opening back up the summer's
gonna be
possible that's what i'm saying your boy
that's why your boys
do lax was popping look at lax no
i'm saying like i'm just saying like
when we were there last time no like uh
when i went to go pick up my dad from
the airport it was like it took me
forever to get to his
uh his terminal he was probably with two
people just like
that's what like what are you talking
about people moving from l.a there were
so many [ __ ]
the best part about covid was no traffic
in l.a i thought i went to lax in
18 minutes like it was nothing
to be the only car on the front come on
man come on easy [ __ ]
wait till we get to the airport this
wednesday naples give me a nightmare
i know yeah the airport's packed yeah
it's popping yeah it wasn't you're
better hey where are your best because
of monday night though
when i picked my dad up we go on
wednesday afternoon i'm saying like i
wonder if it was because it was a monday
night that i was just so lit
no usually sundays it's lit because
everyone's coming out coming back
i mean it's just busy yeah it's lit now
where your best
well yeah bro i'm going to take my shirt
off probably by
july july what um you take it off in zoo
yeah july 4th july in the fitness day
all right yeah [ __ ] it check it
out get it popping you're gonna post a
picture shirtless on instagram that's
gonna be sick
july 4th you heard it here first yeah
july 4th
yeah yeah are you going to post your
before photo with it
or just oh i might you know if you do a
photo you should have shown them before
yeah
i showed you it i don't think so i want
to see it though
no one's seen mine
july 4th we're taking the teas off yeah
you wanna do july four yeah it's gonna
be a firework it looks like no carb june
no [ __ ] no all right i'm happy for y'all
and then about that time i'll be 200 i
i'll take a shirtless [ __ ]
yeah you can't get in the zoo until
you're two hundo i talked to bradley i
was like because he's doing like some
boxing stuff sketches i was like bro
lace me next time you do it he was like
he just read it
he responded yeah chin what's easy
this gut do baby just bring it up for us
on the screen chen go for it
well you should show people chef because
you're motivated oh my god
you're motivating people so bad your gut
was out of control for a while
no send it to your macbook you know so i
stroll around my house with my undies
right now
there you go yeah there you go did you
not used to do that before
no no well i'm still out here wearing
lungs i'd wear a shirt to bed and jet
so you know how fat kids were oh what
that gut do baby
[Laughter]
i'm bullying everybody for that [ __ ]
you're getting all the sticky buns
all the sticky bugs
is
but you know what i i've been like that
since i was uh a kid your face was that
black and white
yeah any of you doesn't look funny yeah
you do yeah it looks like
very uh gnarly farmer's town in my
opinion yeah i think that's
i think that's all it is did you used to
have the same town when you were
cheerleading and fit
no because like you probably were you
know you know what's odd it's like it's
just always been that
yeah exactly that sure about counting i
gotta get i don't know we leave this up
for the fans so that you can motivate
them
you want me to i think so i thought july
right now might as well then right now
yeah we're going in right now and then
we're live are we live right now
completely up to you if you're watching
with it we live right now yeah
no i like your hair there oh well i
appreciate that but
man get that present hey i mean
don't get me wrong i still got like but
but a lot has left but even when we're
in cleveland you came out with your
shirt off and me and jay we're like damn
daddy don't hurt him i'm trying
i'm trying i just wanna you could tell
that your body is like oh you can you
lose a little bit of weight you lose a
little bit of weight
he got that body weight he's like you
push they put their hands
276. bro
it was never 276. everybody knows dude
you la7 there
what what i think you la-7 there were
that time
a lot of hot guys on christmas yeah
there is there's a lot of hot guys jody
want a thug
shot seven yeah
yeah be honest okay that's that's
christopher will be a four he crossed
that street here four okay
so he crossed over as soon as i head
north down
yeah it will number slowly the numbers
just keep going down
it went from hot cheetos to apple yeah
it's like it's like the gas does the
tattoo on your
collarbone say raw power yeah raw powder
hell yeah
yeah iggy pop and the stooges yeah one
of my favorite
uh albums you should have all band
tattoos all band tattoos yeah yeah you
look like a mexican right there you just
look buff
what okay you do yeah yeah if you don't
show your gut you look fine you look
like
you have muscles oh really and this is
so people just even like god doesn't
look bad
no you gotta get there's no run look how
it like
sit like i didn't do dawg it was so hard
for me to uh
you know trim me up could you not see it
anymore no
yeah it was tough you had to pull that
gut up i had to pull the gut up that's
the worst you guys i've never had to do
that i've been there dawg
you know what i'm laying down and [ __ ]
yep it has like light on it
yeah is that what the pregnant women do
yeah pregnant women have to lay down
with the mirror or have someone else do
it for them or you should just just
pretty sure they're just watching i was
taking wild guesses
you got that family matter yeah and then
dude to tie my shoes and [ __ ] yeah that
family
breathing all right super hard to tie my
shoes man i feel you dog
you know go ahead bro my dad my dad got
a good job yeah
straight up yeah he did he got cut good
yeah
but how about facetiming my dad
yesterday and we used to argue all the
time i'm much better now i just let him
tell his [ __ ] and i'm like all right
whatever dude i don't stick up for my
stance anymore
he's like yeah i mean your stepmom on
her diet i'm like oh that's cool me too
and i like had my shirt off it's about
pull he's like yeah you look like you've
been lifted like i'm back at it daddy
and he's like yeah that's cool he's like
you know me and what's my dad
he's like not sexual
you know my dad's in shape he's like
yeah i mean your stepmom are down six
pounds
and he's like well deborah's down six
i'm down 10. i'm like damn 10 pounds a
lot because he's 224 but he's like in
shape
oh he works out all the time he's like
yeah we're going low carb you know we
actually
we've been eating a lot of ravioli
because those are like the lower cu
what what i don't say anything like that
that's cool low carb ravioli i'm like
like
the pasta ravioli he's like yeah cause
out of all the pastas the lee's carbs
like
that's not true at all but i don't i'm
like
selling but i'm like oh good for you man
he's like and then also
who knows we love key lime pie and
that's actually health spray because the
limes and i was like
what yeah i was like oh that too good
for you man you're serious huh
does your dad just have good genetics
yeah okay but that does seem like an
older generation
man i was like yeah we've been eating
ravioli the carbs aren't crazy
yeah he goes the car there's low carbs
like oh my god you're so off yeah
way off dude right if i was eating
homemade key lime pie you know
it's lime so you know that's healthy
like i've never had
a key lime pie
i need to get one for his birthday
stevie when stevie's birthday i don't
like
may 19th better get a good one yeah i
might get the one from castaway that was
good
that one's good it's a little too sweet
for me i don't know if you like real
stuff
key lime pie with like a nice dark
coffee and that one
it's yeah a little sweet for me do you
like real real sweet uh
i like pogs but i never heard of this i
swear key lime pie if it's done well
now it's the worst pie if it's not done
right it's the worst pie in the world
but if it's done right it's fantastic
yeah i can't
what do you mean like it's not done
right like it's the shitty pie
if you have red lobster or key lime pie
to come like [ __ ]
but you go you get like a real key lime
pie like we'll be in floyd i bet naples
have good kilos
stevie coming to naples uh no he's not
in miami we had joe
stone crab they're known for the key
lime pie it's [ __ ] and it was good
it's amazing oh
so it's so brilliant
oh on saturday um stevie and i are going
to an alpaca farm
for what his favorite animal is an
alpaca where dude he has one like a
stuffed alpaca right next to his knight
nice hand oh yeah yeah he has a
that'd be sick oh yeah he already has a
homer wait he should or i should
he should oh he's like kuzma
oh cusco that's what you're thinking of
cuzco is that a i think he's a llama
though
is to become rich enough to have a home
where he can have two alpacas
just chilling because they're docile you
can do that yeah
it's not okay i mean now
yeah i don't know how much those little
things are what is it like what do you
say
alpaca is a very very docile version of
a llama
don't they spin on you though oh yeah
those are the ones that spit but alpacas
spit two oh
it just got real let's get it here it
goes
one thing about me if my lungs green and
my foxes are popping i'm a happy dude
that dad life
one thing we take pride in is our lawn
and the greens around the yard so guess
what springs around the corner
that means it's time to get the lawn
back on track you don't be the only
house on the block with that brown lawn
don't do that man
all right we got you covered man sunday
is more
than just lawn care product talk about
sunday lawn care products
it's a customized lawn plan that works
with nature they take
all the guesswork and unwanted chemicals
so you can grow a beautiful lawn that's
better for people
pets planets your kids we got you
covered man it's super easy
you can attach to your hose and get to
work all you have to do is go to
gitsunday.com
put in your home address their free lawn
analysis tool will take care of the rest
in just seconds
sunday uses soil and climate data create
tailored nutrition plan
so you get all the stuff for your lawn
that they want to eat they want to eat
on up so it gets all
green all right sunday explains exactly
what you need and why
everything is sent straight to your door
right when you need it all right we got
you covered man and all you have to do
is attach the ready to use pouch to a
garden hose and spray away
lawn care used to take up the whole day
not now 15 minutes or less best of all
this stuff actually works
milan is so goddamn green man let sunday
take the guesswork out of growing a
greener more beautiful lawn this spring
visit getsunday.com fighter get 20 off
your custom lawn plan at checkout
it's 20 off your custom plan at
getsunday.com
fighter this quarantine was crazy man
think about all the purchase you made on
late night pizza deliveries
all sorts of weird food your online
trainer all right there's a there you
made a ton of bad choices there's one
of your biggest purchases of the year
we're talking about insurance america's
overspend on car and home insurance by
billions every year
that's money that can be spent on all
things much better why waste money
that's where the zebra can help you the
zebra's nation's leading insurance
comparison site
for cars and home insurance in minutes
you can compare policies from every
major provider for free all in one
independent marketplace
after a few quick questions the zebra
appears people with the right insurance
company
for them helping everyone save time and
money
all right they're no hidden fees or fine
print about your personal information we
got you covered it's safe reliable
best of all the zebra has no stake in
the policy you choose they don't care
just trying to save you money man just
here
to find the right coverage that's right
for you make insurance your smartest
purchase yeah visit the zebra.com
fighter that's t-h-e-z-e-b-r-a dot com
slash fighter
let's get it here it goes
hell yeah looking good got the mask on
damn fresh shaved man
yeah yeah you know you came from new
york you're still rocking the mask all
the time
i know yeah i'm like
i'm glad you're doing it i'm glad you
said it
i was thinking in my heart but i got
sponsored
i was feeling the same vibe
what are you doing in l.a brother uh
pods
just pause you were in austin before
this
yeah yeah and you just came out there to
do pods too well i
chose addison and then i went to pogba
oh dallas
in dallas oh great club it's a great my
favorite yeah it's a good spot
great spot and the hotel's right there
so then you drove down from dallas to
austin
i went from austin i drove from austin
uh no drove from dallas to austin yeah i
did a couple days there and then i've
been here then what'd you do in austin
like what all shows did you get i did
um i did lex friedman's podcast okay
i did tim's podcast timmy dillon timmy
dylan
um and you and tim know each other from
new york yeah yeah are we on
we're on oh [ __ ] oh so we were on when i
came in yeah yeah
oh i didn't know that i got that yeah
i'm sorry
i apologize don't be sorry he didn't
know i'm sorry about that
yeah i didn't know that yeah
yeah you got to tell me yeah yeah but he
was about to let some more [ __ ]
i was about to yeah wow
that's why i had that reaction it's like
jesus la's gotten crazy
i was just kidding christian's all yeah
he just started his [ __ ]
so he did lex friedman with him like you
know it was funny like i didn't know i
was trying to tell us like is this his
podcast voice or are we just talking
because it sounded like
i thought we were just talking like hey
you know when you go off air it's a
little more casual yeah
but you sounded real podcasty and that's
i was like are we on yeah and i was like
oh
and then it hit my brian i was like
that's why people reacted
like he's a smart intellectual yeah so
we were able to get off some jokes on
there or yeah i was able to get off some
jokes and he just kind of laughed like a
ha ha
like you know he's a yeah he's an
intellectual he's an a.i
yeah great dude smart smart [ __ ] dude
yeah
he's creating he's building robots and
he's out in austin too
he's out in austin did he just move
there he just moved there god get off
broken
everybody everyone's moving yeah that's
he does he does jiu-jitsu too i think
yeah yeah
he's a is he a black belt or are we
talking about him i think he knows
jiu-jitsu he's a fan of it or he
actually
no he does it he has a flower dude oh he
does yeah when i see that cauliflower i
don't [ __ ] around that's like a
the cauliflower air is like a adt
sticker for your face
it's like you know you go to a lawn and
you see like security protected that's
what i see that [ __ ] i'm like i'm not
trying don't [ __ ] with it now this guy
mit
he's mit yeah i met you smart [ __ ]
dude very smart
i like him what kind of jits are we
talking about here though i think he's
like i don't know dude
he may be able to know how to choke out
nano robots or something he's also from
mit and he's kind of short a little bit
he's a little short but not
that don't matter yeah not with jiu
jitsu oh okay
yeah that was a good podcast so he's
[ __ ] timmy's who
timmy's on fire yeah jimmy doesn't miss
yeah tim my favorite people ever
yeah he's a friend that was fun then i
did lex and i did drinking bros which is
the hat i'm wearing i believe yeah
those guys are cool damn that was the
only podcast i ever did where there was
a loaded gun on the table
oh wow that's like welcome to chat
drinking bros is with who
uh dan and uh you don't know his last
name that's fine
no dan holloway and james st james
[ __ ] if i [ __ ] that up that's weird now
james st james is from a party oh dude
those are my guys
it's from black rifle black rifle yeah
yeah the one with the one on the right
was the director
of uh the movie i did
and the guy in the middle is from uh
black rifle too
yeah i don't know the guy on the left
but they all can shoot guns and kill
people yeah yeah yeah
for sure yeah former military no they're
fun they're
fun they're super silly yeah they're fun
oh this is good it's fun it's just a
different jerry taylor's my boy ross was
the director i don't know
dan holloway but jared taylor's my guy
ross they're both very bond man
very funny it used to be matt best but i
think he got off of it
so now those guys are in there that best
we had them up we had them more yeah
matt basketball yep yeah
very cool back rightful yeah those dudes
you're just busy out there
do you mean link up with rogan too i did
link up with rogan yeah we did barbecue
at terry's
yeah and he's opening a club man he is
have you seen it
i haven't seen it yet pretty dope i had
to leave town but i'm going to go i'm
going back in the 20th to 24th to do
shows and he's on
of uh april april yeah when are we there
april 20 april 22nd through the 20th
let's go buy sneakers together
oh yeah let's go shopping yeah okay yeah
are you there you're there when we're
there
i'm there when you're there yep [ __ ]
look at that
let's make tick-tock videos
collaboration let's make a
video
it's like where all the tick tock
dancers get molested by their manager no
what it's wrong
how
it's like all the big biggest tick
tockers or youtubers just get a big ass
mansion
state and like do all they read it out
yeah and they live there correct
that's fantastic oh it's like some big
manager
puts them all together there they're all
like 20 21.
we're too old yeah they go to the
they're all their office is like the
foyer of the mansion they meet they like
brainstorm right
like what are we going to lip sync you
know for seven seconds today and then
they just do it yeah
and then they make millions of dollars
yeah they just make millions
and they do the same three moves yeah
okay and then any time the n-word comes
up they just go
it's true
we'll have a version of that because we
got a dope ass airbnb right off sixth
street there
let's do a collect let's do a
tic-tac-toe
what venue are you i'll cancel them off
if we get if we get serious about this
tick tock idea
i cut them off you can't blow up what
are you thinking the fighter in the kids
and the greek
yeah something like that fighter in the
greek and the kids it's the wire season
two yeah the wire season two
oh yeah yeah we do [ __ ] what you did
there kid and play kickstarter yeah
exactly all these people want to watch a
couple of 30-year-olds do that though
i feel like dude there's a lot of
[ __ ] divorcees who want to fight
you know i mean it's an underserved
market on tick-tock think about it
facebook started young
okay and then it went old tick-tock
started young
now we flip it we get in we start the
trend too fresh though it's too fresh to
flip no it's been outside now for a
while man
yeah i haven't done a tick tock yet so
yeah what what uh venue are you doing
austin
uh i can't remember what it's called
it's a club there i can't remember
there's so many spots now in austin
like we're i'm we're at the vulcan gas
company theater it's right off sixth
street there yeah
i know yeah i saw that spot that's a fun
one can't remember what it's called but
it might be that
you're there before me it's ashoka it's
like four people
i don't know i never pay attention that
stuff till like the day of did you post
it i'm not an organized person i haven't
posted anything no
go go to a vulcan gas company
i'll tell you what it is website jen
let's see before me is dope city tour
david lucas death squad secret shows
there
i'm at the sunset it's called uh the
sunset strip
comedy comedy room sunset strip comedy
room
that's rematch and then i'm doing
another show on the 20th a solo so i
don't know what i'm doing
but you're there yeah it gave me a
couple you know a couple dollars i said
yeah you know i'll go back
let's do it let's do it and we got to
get sneakers now
let's go let's go get sneakers because
you guys got to pay back brandon for
yeah
yeah i still don't have yeah
when you guys go on the road together do
they just encourage you to bring like
four or five just for fire they're like
yo you gotta switch them every day and
then you just
you got one missing every weekend listen
well jordan can you bring that left
jordan one this time like what's up
yeah you gotta switch it up just for
pictures man
my boy derek posted on there i don't
know yeah i love the picture
yeah they use a picture of me like you
know before i started taking
antiretroviral drugs for aids
i mean i'm this is when i was suffering
yeah i'm just joking i'm skinny i'm
skinny
can we bleep any of this stuff no
this is live yeah so that first one i
hit was just out to the universe
the street's on it now man yeah
that's such a funny picture that's
a campaign what are you thinking i was
thinking like richard nixon you know
like
yeah yeah that's a good lineup though
yeah and that's pretty that's it
that fred perry is pre-proud boy fred
perry okay no
i mean no fred how disappointed is fred
perry
kid had a hot like very high-end
uh fashion line that just got co-opted
by
white supremacy yeah it's tough that's a
tough one dude
yeah huh take that out start a new
start a new fashion line is that is uh
the vocal and gas game is that where
tony does um kill tonia too no he
doesn't like he does it all over right
did he do it at tubs barbecue is it tubs
or chubs
stubs i don't think he does that i think
chubbs
[ __ ] theater he just he just posted
about it
dude did you see darnell rawlings on uh
kill tony donnell yeah get lit up uh no
no no what happened well you know you
know do you know what kill tony is
yes so they have like all the local
comics come up they get one minute
and uh he was you know he always has a
guest on the show
and he had um darnell
rawlings on as the guest and i think is
it david lucas's name
lit him up no david no david lucas is
the one that lights up people
i don't think it was him though i forget
so someone went out wait a second
donnell did stand up on it no no they
have a guest right so they have a guest
i critique the
the the other comics and there's like a
panel like it's like red band tony and
then a big guess right big guess was
darnell rawlings
this kid went up there and lit [ __ ]
went straight at darnell and started
lighting them up
and lit darno up so bad darling i was
like i don't need this [ __ ] it was going
to walk off
wow that wow and the like dropped the
mic when he started making
fun of because uh he's wearing uh dave
chappelle's chain can i get dave
chappelle gives his crew a chain
would you wear another man's chain no no
but dino is my boy i mean i love darnell
he's a legend
i know he's such a beast don i was kind
of the guy who gave me my start in
comedies oh really
yeah he uh you will darnell chain though
huh you'd wear his chain
no okay i wouldn't wear another guy you
better rock that unless i was in jail
and like
we were in jail together i you know yeah
if you feel like i'm i'm a chokie i'll
[ __ ] your weird channel where you change
yeah
if you gave me that much or if you like
protect me my entire like stint like my
hard six years there yeah and he like
protect me like i didn't get raped and
stuff yeah
i probably had tattoos i'll probably get
a tattoo
i get a lower transparent
how did he get your stuff he um so i
quit comedy like i started comedy and
then i quit comedy i you know i got i
got
i got shot in new york like we talked
about yeah yeah and i had panic attacks
for a while and then
donnell had a show once a week and this
was right
at the beginning of chappelle shows like
2006. so i would do stand-up once a week
and new york
in new york it was called uh poke it was
called uh
marion square okay on east 95th if you
ever have him on he'll tell you about it
and the show was crazy i mean donnell
would get drunk we would have fun
and i was you know just getting back and
he would convince he was like yo son
you're funny
you know he's still a son so have you
sean come on yeah so i would perform
once a week and then he took me on the
road with him and charlie and burr
wow
and uh yeah i had some good stories with
charlie just me and charlie walking
around the mall
those dudes were that was like the last
big cable show that was like the last
that was right before the internet kind
of yep
i mean it popped it was like the last
big it was obviously the biggest cable
show comedy show
but i mean those dudes i'm charlie
murphy superstar famous
but the thing with charlie and char i
mean i'm not
talking about turner but also charlie
when he started stand up he wasn't doing
it long enough he was like just telling
stories
and then they paired him up with rogan
so as rogan and charlie murphy
then you go on the road and then charlie
murphy would headline but romero rogan's
doing kindly for like 25 30 years
so he's a seasoned comic so rogan's
trying to help him out like dude
i should go after you like it's not an
ego thing it's just a
optics thing like you should really let
me go after you well he had the same
problem with dunnellon burr
because it was the the tour was burr
donnell yeah
and and and charlie jesus and donnell
when he
when he connects
yes so at first donnell was closing and
burr
this before burr was pop-pop but he was
bur would kill he's always been a savage
a bird would kill any room yeah bro
would go into black rooms like i started
in black rooms in brooklyn
bur the only white guys you'd see in
there is voss and burr
burke coming in donnell's famous room
called poke knockers
um where uh uh mike apps got knocked out
one night
some dude just punch i don't know what
happens um
i remember burr first thing he said when
he got up there all black room
in uh in brooklyn he goes uh burgos ah
good to be good uh good to be back in
the old neighborhood
rush burr's a killer killer dude so but
that does so when charlie murphy was
starting to have highly
requested that he had a famous and donna
was like all right
so i think like they went donnell went
out there to intentionally bury him
because they had like this funny
competitive thing and he would
and then you know charlie would come up
and charlie was getting better at stand
up considering how little he'd been
doing it
yeah but i mean donnell was is a
seasoned guy that would just
deny l.a especially those guys and
especially his style too so charlie was
new but also
his style's kind of slow it's a story
and and storytelling
and drawn out and donnell's just machine
gun old noises
[ __ ] animated such a beast
so uh so then so then would charlie just
headline or did he take charlie started
headlining at the end
and he would do okay but it was uh you
know the show the pace of the show would
go
i mean i think donnell would host
towards the end then burr
and they would both just cross massacre
like
massive yeah but that's an ego thing
like when charlie murphy see that i'm
like all right it was an eagle thing
because charlie was really the draw
at that point this was before burr was
really a draw but
he still still wasn't that yeah and
donnell was known as ashley larry but
charlie murphy was like below like it
was chappelle and then charlie murphy
for sure
those stories really blew up the prince
and the huge rick james
dude those still hold up i watched them
yeah they're so [ __ ] funny so funny
man i like skinny chappelle i like when
you're
skinny yeah before you start working out
get buffed yeah yeah yeah before you get
on trt shabbat yeah yeah
[Music]
i mean his frame doesn't look like you
know i don't know i don't know enough
about it i know cool skinny chapel
he was so thin yeah do you mind if i get
a water
water yeah and he started wearing like
t-shirts and [ __ ]
would you would you would you wear
another man's chain
malik no we already talked about that we
talked about in the car
oh i'm sorry yeah i wouldn't oh anywhere
no that that fits this frame no that
makes sense
nice yeah at least pro protein powder
yeah at least protein
protein that was me yeah that was like
malik this this you this is your
transformation exactly
dude well he was 24. go to that one into
four
when don't you kill me sofia ball game
look how big he is
did he start doing uh stamp at like 14
basketball games
but still the maturity of that for 24.
watch that god
damn dave oh he was way ahead and that
killing himself
he did way ahead that's one of the most
classic special
ever i found i was 24 i almost quit i
was like
why am i doing this that's like seeing
jordan play basketball
yeah it's just not for me man yeah it's
like yeah well that's jordan
you know like there's there's room yeah
eddie was 24 for delirious dude
yeah how nuts is that yeah you watch
that you're like jesus christ
yeah no he was 22 for delirious twenty
four four
twenty two for delirious in the red
leather
[ __ ] and that's those specials still
hold up
still oh i watched oh no watch we
watched we watched the raw
in texas oh monster dude that was like
back when
you could say the f word you could see i
mean his whole special he was saying oh
yeah
yeah and he was saying it he was saying
in the context of that
i was saying in a different context like
yeah like you know like like now
netflix i was saying like it's not a
slur he was saying it like a sword but
yeah
but those were the times where did you
cancel eddie over that you know like
that's his
that was the times you couldn't cancel
eddie yeah yeah you can't cancel that
but then also if it lets you know
eddie's supposed to do a special so
let's say really special now but had all
those f words in it
i even though it's eddie murphy i
guarantee you netflix won't let it right
not in this climate no but he would he
wouldn't even he was talking like he's
no way i would he goes
no i would never do those jokes again
yeah but netflix would never
never neverland they wouldn't want to
deal with that [ __ ] but netflix has
those specials up
yeah they do because of those in the
context okay that was they did yeah
80s come on man it was yeah that'd be
funny if they just dub it with something
else
with like maggots look at all these
maggots oh yeah they would be
fun what the [ __ ] is this yeah they just
have uh
yeah what's nanette's name her her her
voice over it and she just says what she
wants yeah
yeah unnoticed she says that's the
i can't remember her name because
nanette everyone just called her nanette
or they just or every time he says the f
word they just have a picture of
uh a video of ship i'm sorry uh eddie
murphy now and he's one
yeah but he's just all old as [ __ ] oh
hannah hannah
and that's not her name not her name got
it yeah
should you please replace uh crystalline
in that uh action mode no
she did not it was it was two wait
that's not rachel maddow
that's not rachel hey that's you
i think you guys are not
yeah wrong i'll tell you what some fan
did dude when that when that
special came out some fan because i made
a joke about i mean i tweeted about
how her next special was going to be at
the apollo because like
you know and somebody cut her special in
with apollo
hilarious no the audience and it was
like she was doing her jokes like her
the dry whatever
and then the crowd was going crazy
i mean that that would be a funny show
idea to put comics
in rooms maybe that like not their
audience or at least just take
any comic and put them in front of a
black audience no
because you got 10 to 20 seconds to
bring it get it going yes
if you lean against the wall for one
second it's a wrap you'll just hear a
black woman in the crowd suck her teeth
so hard
and you'll hear like uh-uh
and if you're good you hear what you
hear the dudes go wow
wow black kids be hitting that wow
wow wow hey that's funny that's good
because i need it right and uh so he was
like yo you give me up
he went up he was a white comic white
guy
in the hood is it is it is it a good
white comic
like he's slow like it's dry yeah but
you got it but you can't you can't
you can't bring that yeah yeah you gotta
go kick your leg you gotta really yeah
every word you gotta dance cause it's
a snapchat crowd you only have ten
seconds to catch their uh attention span
and black crowds want they wanna feel
that you are funny yeah
yeah they don't wanna know your material
they wanna be like you're funny just
just like a vehicle
yeah yeah let me see this uh cut of
hannah
oh here it is
i've never seen it so funny dude
he did this on my tweet
[Laughter]
it's so funny
comfortable in a small town i get a bit
tense uh mainly because i'm in this
situation
do you know blue is a cold color it's on
the cold end of the spectrum
but the hottest part of the flame blue
where does that come from
you're stuck in traffic you're trying to
hear booze
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay
where's the saying man
[Applause]
keep going
[Applause]
why does she get so much heat for it's
just a special heat was just
the heat was because like the woke
laughs it made that
this is how special should be and it was
more of like a ted talk there was like
an article
oh she she was quoted as saying like uh
comedy shouldn't be funny anymore it
should be like
instructive so the whole thing was like
a ted talk and she was kind of just
the whole thing was kind of just like
you guys are bad yeah i was like
opinions yeah oh
like how toxic male 1
she's a feminist lesbian from from
australia so the whole thing was kind of
like
i don't get how like that why like why
that would need to be comedy like why
can't comedy just
be she's a comedian she did the special
and then
all these articles immediately just came
out praising them praising it
praise it as like the [ __ ] oh this is
the new comedy then society is like
society was like huh yeah if you push it
like that i'm gonna i'm gonna watch it
yeah
and so everybody watching it was like
everyone watched it and uh people hated
it including gay people like my
brother's gay and he was like what
like he just didn't give yeah i had i
knew someone who went to see her who's
gay
and she j like it was a live performance
in new york and she just started bombing
and screaming at the crowd
and got angry and like walked off so
it's like yeah it was one of those
things for me it was just further
evidence that like hey man when you get
in that system that system has an agenda
and they try to tell you what's good or
bad and it's based on like yeah the
public decides
wait what do you what do you mean like
the the entertainment system
the machine the machine this is funny
now yeah
easy for them to write the article and
put the [ __ ] out but it doesn't because
it's different yeah you got the battery
behind
yeah there's like exactly and then
they're going like they're they're go
not only are they going like here this
is what we're going to show you they're
going like
this is what good is so you read the
article and i guess people go and i get
i guess it's good but then you watch it
you go like that doesn't
it that didn't move
rave reviews i bet for her audience they
loved it oh so she's probably still
killing it
oh yeah i think it's for her i think
it's falling a lot i
don't i don't know much about it yeah i
think i don't know but i don't know
yeah i don't know but for her lane maybe
they'd probably [ __ ] with it
yeah her yeah her specific audience as
far as comedy you show up and it's just
like a bunch of lesbian couples
just sitting there with haircuts like
mine yeah
it's not going to be so strong she's got
she's got her audience she can't perform
in front of
uh divert it's it's the irony is she
could never perform in front of a
diverse crowd
that's what's always irony to me is like
you go to some of those like all rooms
or you used to a couple years ago
yeah and it was like all this
righteousness and you go like this is
the whitest comedy show i've ever been
to
like everyone in the audience is white
yeah you know so
you you would do a lot of black rooms
when i started i started doing black
rooms yeah which is like scary
yeah they're scary it's the best because
i think the
part of it you get so scared at the
beginning it gets easier than that and
also you realize that hey man it's a
performance
yes like you can't just lean up in new
york a lot like
this is where we we lack too cool for
school
yeah we kind of lean back and we're like
yeah did you hear the joke though
yeah structure the material like dude
you're telling you're telling jokes
you're not [ __ ] painting a picasso
nobody gives you so it's like bringing
it back and
like you know just like the the craft
where it's like l.a
it performs it it's like more a little
more theatrical and in black rooms you
have to perform
yeah you can't and black people aren't
going to write a blog if you say
something no they're not going to get
blocked he's going to let you know right
there
right you know christmas
you'll hear it next time is there a loud
cough
it's a focusing story where there was
just uh a [ __ ] chicken wing bone got
thrown out no
that big j yeah kevin hart have you ever
had my hunt
have you ever have a month i love big j
dude the philly store
kevin hart was hosting and like yeah he
started bombing and then
he used to do this thing i don't want to
ruin it but i'll just tell you quickly
he used to do this thing where he
stripped naked at the end because he's
big bad person yeah yeah it's before you
know he's
an amazing comment yeah yeah it's like
at the beginning you know we're all
trying to get laughs so he would strip
down naked as a big fat dude and the
crowd would go crazy
but he was doing this show of the black
black room in philly kevin hart was
hosting
and he was getting ready for his closer
which usually brings you how
crazy he's like all right he starts
stripping and at one point he just
he said he hears some black women go
jesus
and then he gets naked he just sees a
chicken bone just hit him
[Laughter]
and then he's done he does the big
finale it's silent then he's got to like
gather up all his clothes i'm silent oh
yes he's still got him just
rolls rolling down all shitty committed
to that [ __ ]
just built like a baby hippo getting all
[ __ ]
that's my time guys yeah that's what
he had a serious show with uh dan soder
i think they still do it they still do
it they're great together
they're so [ __ ] funny two of the
funniest guys the funniest ever dance
from denver so i always [ __ ] with dan
but he was he was saying that you know
obviously he came up with kevin hart and
philly and he was like yeah and then you
know kevin blew up and
i did i didn't know how to you know i
was like yeah i see him phil he may want
to come through and he's like yeah sure
man
and he's like so i come up there and
whenever we're on the road i used to
always bring the xbox
and i was the xbox guy he's like so i
come with my xbox i get in there
and ken's like man what the [ __ ] you
doing he's like what he has like all the
old controllers
and kevin's like what the [ __ ] are you
doing they're like in this penthouse
he's like
i prepped the xbox he
that's the moment where you're just
really clearly going oh yeah we're in
two associates
you buy one every season cat and we just
leave them for the
night like you invite your richer friend
over to your house and he comes over for
five seconds and he's like all right man
let's just let's go to my place
we always go to your place
[Laughter]
you know comedy's hard like that when
you come up with guys because guys
pop at different times and they're
friends yeah and a lot of times it's
actually
challenging yeah jealousy starts
happening and guys start
you you hear it all the time you look
back i've heard from all the comics you
know they got into fights because
one guy started popping the other guy
and it's just that's tough relationships
but then also you hear it all the time
he's not even funny yeah yeah
yeah well some people think he's really
funny yeah like he's selling out on the
road you really he's not funny he's got
to be doing something he's doing
something yeah
yeah yeah he's not that's there's
nothing funny he's last special it's
like oh god dude
yeah it's like somebody thinks he's
funny he's doing something
that room full of people who are
laughing think he's funny yeah yeah you
may not
yeah doing something right it's like
it's funny too when the whenever you
hear like uh comic critique other comics
like a bitter comic
you always notice that the the ones they
like are always like most like them
correct you know you're like it's just
themselves
yeah they see something they're like
that's good it's like you know that's
what you do yeah yeah i used to hate
what it's no different about you hear
that new drake oh it's terrible it's
like ah man i enjoyed it
like he's doing something right dude
like massive amounts of people like him
yeah i used to hate when a new comic
would drop a special and then you go to
the comedy store
and you're like do you hear blah blah's
new special and before i come like yeah
they'd be like a terrible yeah
like ah [ __ ] really yeah you know so i
would i would just nip in the body
fantastic and i'd walk off like
fantastic
the thing about like hacks is hacks are
hilarious
even if it's like hacking where you're
like a hack is means that they're just
like
doing hacky [ __ ] but it's crushing yeah
and that's why they're getting called a
hack yeah so it's like i don't know if
you're an ordinary person you come out
you're not like a comedy snob
you know i'd probably want to see yeah
yeah yeah if you're not a super balls
demon comedy yeah
i don't want to see like bill hicks up
there you're working all week and then
bill hicks comes and tells you your
country's full of [ __ ] you're gonna die
you're like dude
i'm working on a [ __ ] mill all week
yeah come on bring out the puppet yeah
from the palisades from like he rented
some big ass crib might have been his
crib he just released it during covet
do you see that oh just his last sp on
comedy central i watched the one he
didn't he
he wrote it didn't tour at all and just
did a special on it it's him in the
puppets yeah that's genius
yeah yeah it's different because yeah
when we were in phoenix he was doing uh
uh what i was gonna stand up live and
i'm like okay how many they'll sell out
they're like a hundred more tickets to
go you should sell i'm like oh [ __ ] i
was all hype
and then i'm like we were like walking
the streets it was like two in the
afternoon
and across the street at the phoenix
suns arena i'm like it's
cars around like who the [ __ ] over
there like jeff dunham i'm like
he has a two o'clock show that he is two
four six eight and then he gets the [ __ ]
out
like what yeah sold out like six times
in one night
dude i think he's one of the richest
comics he is yeah my dad loves him yeah
a lot of people alone it's like a lot of
fun
they're fantastic beyonce coming out
[ __ ] yeah a bunch of wrestlers he
does
he does his like a little thing uh
before like he'll do like
without the puppets like i think for
like 10-15 minutes
especially he does like 10-15 minutes of
straight-up stand-up and then out then
you see the [ __ ]
puppies come up case come out he's like
he was like oh
yeah the girl's like oh my god oh my god
i'd go see it live yeah i would
talk about a guy who probably wouldn't
be able to have a netflix special now
you can't do like
what is it ahmed the town yeah the
terrorist puppet oh i think he retired
him though like
he got woke with it he's like you know
i'm not bringing odd bad at it anymore
really yeah he had like a terrorist
probably
like what was it like i killed you yeah
like you yeah yeah yeah i don't think
you're
right yeah you update with it yes i hate
jews
everyone's all yeah not anymore yeah the
[ __ ] americans going yeah
the one that controls the weather
that was like the last like big uh tour
as far as like a group of like
dope ass comics you talking about that
white color blue blue color commentary
i think so for white comics yeah well
like going to do like an arena tour
right that's pretty good they were doing
it right and then kovitz shut it down
i think they'll probably go back out and
then because they were doing it they are
they yeah and they're doing math square
but when you think of something like the
kings of comedy yeah you're like just
like
like four hearts just like more hard
hitters but the
the difference with kings of comedy is
remember that
nobody really popped off yeah no of
course they did they were huge they were
huge
on the stand-up scenes
so you gotta remember and then steve
harvey put it all together he was the
business behind it
and then he pitched everyone was like
this is how much you're gonna get
i don't want any issues and i forget
what comic gave him [ __ ] was like man
well i think i should have this he's
like you're out
and that's how dl got in was someone
else supposed to be honest oh i think it
was
you know they made a movie about that
was it guy tori i forget
someone else was so totally made a
mistake
steve harvey's like oh we can't have
that and then cedric the entertainer was
crushing so hard
early on the tour they're like dude you
need to you need to go last
yeah because he was crushing it they
said the same thing about bernie they
said they put
bernie last year he was crushing so he's
like it was switch it up let's switch it
up but but the
the thing with that is and you could do
it now but you'd it's tough now
right so you i try putting together but
guys you're going to take a hit
so but my this is my logic with it like
we did a show where it was ari theo
myself and big j and it's like in
phoenix in phoenix
and we did that the orpheum which is
like 4 000 people and we
sold it out we're gonna do two shows
this is like two years ago okay
two and a half years ago but the thing
is that you can go on tour like that you
can't go back to that city so the pitch
is like yeah you're gonna take less
money but maybe ahri's fans out there
who haven't seen you they're gonna like
you whatever the 15 minutes you did you
get tour the next week dude
and you're because you're doing your
full hour yeah so it's not killing those
markets
but guys it's impossible with comics
like well i make 60 grand torn in
phoenix i'm like no i get that dude yeah
yeah yeah yeah you're just doing
15 dropped you're just doing 15 and then
it's going to build up when you go back
in that circle he's still making good
money doing 15. but it's a hang
it's one night look man people make
these decisions like they're going to
[ __ ] live forever
yeah yeah i want to have fun i hate the
road alone if that if someone came up
like that again i would take less money
for the hey
yeah oh don't make me on the road alone
now i'm going to roll yeah i'll uh you
know bring one uh if i bring an opener
or if uh you know i know somebody in the
town like last time my buddy mike suarez
opened for me and that was cool but
other than that i mean to hang with like
four other of your friends and do a show
together
that's what we do man so like we're in
naples this week we [ __ ]
before you guys like five years ago i
just booked it go solo whatever
comics they booked at that venue i'd go
i'd go back to the hotel by myself eat
by myself
this is [ __ ] terrible yeah you know
but now i should start collabing and
doing on
go on the road and do like podcast tours
together
you could do a podcast or you'd also do
like like they do at comedy festivals
where
thursday nights the podcast friday and
saturday standing love that
that's that's a live podcast and then
friday saturday statements
that's hard that's dope but when you
first started touring you toured poc
live podcast but you also did no i i
never did like i've no
i don't agree with live podcast i
thought y'all did wow you have a moral
style i think he's referring to fighter
in the kids live
yeah so finding kids live was was stand
up and improv
oh it wasn't even like you were saying
brian would not sit down because brian
was like we should do go on the road
this i'm like dude have you ever seen a
live podcast they're [ __ ] terrible
yeah but
we lose our audience a brand's like no
dumbass it's gonna start with you doing
10 minutes of stand up
right and then i'll come out you and i
clown each other riff on each other then
we'd have like bullet points
to bring up and there's jokes and the
bullet points then we go to current
events but it'd be all jokes oh gosh
i saw it and then we do q a i saw burrs
live but that he hiding himself
his podcast he could like i thought it
was dude it was phenomenal right
but it's but that's built i think it's
because he was by himself like
i see what you're saying like i'm not
paying i love pi i listen so many
podcasts but to watch them sit down like
i'm not trying to
to see it like live finding kid live was
a performance that's how that's what got
me my start
stand up yeah we're gonna figure it out
though there's gonna be somebody who
figures out how to make them work
i don't think it's like i guarantee i
figure it out if you do i'm like
assuming
i'm a super poor steve harvey yeah yeah
i don't think it like maybe it's not
like
doing the podcast it's more like a
celebration of the podcast
with like fan interactions your boys
yeah that's right that's what they do at
the 85
show they sell out like arenas
carlos miller dc on fly they started on
uh wilding out
yeah and it was like bro we should just
do a podcast just like yo we'll interact
with our fans on the road because they
know it's about
wilding out right so they started off in
clubs yeah they went to like state uh
arena there are all these headlining
comics all of them are now oh yeah well
now
but at the time were they yeah yeah at
the time they're all [ __ ]
well i think dc on flowers was kind of
like you like he was like like he
wasn't doing stand up a lot but he was
around a person carlos miller who been
doing it for like 23 plus years
like o'brien yeah and he was like bro
let's you go out there and be first
right you have you the one who had 10
million followers on instagram yeah you
go out there first then he had chico
bean who's been doing it for like
yeah yeah right and then he named carlos
with a headline and then they'll just do
and then they come out together you can
figure it out i mean before
covet hit another [ __ ] hit we had a tour
line up with
bobby lee santino brian and me we're
gonna do two shows at the chicago
theater
we'll do big shows in uh new york and
then covet hit and then obviously the
other [ __ ]
yeah yeah but everyone has to be on the
same path to be like all right we're
going to take a hit on this
but we realize it's the long game yeah
there's a long game to it yeah
i mean look what it did for kings of
comedy i mean yeah [ __ ] coming out
with a movie now yeah about that and it
was guy tour you know it's one of the
most underrated movies where all those
guys were in it
um life life come on man that's the only
movie
i was talking about yeah it was harlow i
don't think it's underrated though to me
life's top five
i think it's yeah it's underrated i mean
it didn't do great
nobody talks about it you're totally
right
you know this but eddie murphy told the
director he said let him go he said let
them go let them
let them smile shine yeah because he
goes they'll make it happen
yeah don't try to just let him do it
yeah but think about martin bro like he
was big
on that level and he had to take a
second tier like eddie murphy was the
star
teddy though i know i know but martin he
it was more than lourdes he had a
murphy dude they didn't they did it also
boomerang
and boomerang and another one of the
most underrated come on bro you talking
about uh
marcus graham yeah
eddie let him riff correct eddie and
that was like the most quotable thing
people would quote that uh you got a
chord
yeah that's a great that movie is is
like he had all the baddies in there
yeah harley barry i mean david allen
greer
still gets a lot of action now like i've
told you it's always on watch tv
every time it comes on tv bt or showtime
stars yeah
life is big man yeah yeah i thought it
was like yeah martin lawrence kind of
took more of the straighter role
he was more the straight man he was
great though dude showed his versatility
well that he wasn't like the zany one he
was kind of more than a straight one you
know you talked to somebody on life like
uh eddie murphy was like
you started doing characters and that's
how he came up with big mama house
oh really from yes yeah because yeah
from like really yeah eddie murphy
because you know everybody
martin's great at character yeah he's i
mean you think about his tv show like tv
show
that was my favorite show growing up my
favorite comment
also underrated sp it's not underrated
because
those who know who know you so crazy
you're so crazy
dude that was a great [ __ ] special
killing like a villain let the water
drip
all over y'all hey crazy
[ __ ] you dick man
what was the special he came out with
where like he was that oh that was the
one where after where like he had to
freak out freak out yeah
he wasn't like that he went weird huh
yeah yeah a little weird well yeah what
he kind of got booted from hollywood
they were he said he just smoked some
weed or something
bro he brandon but naked down the street
talking about with a gun talking about
like yo they're after me they're right
yeah he was also in like a sweat suit
he's like doing some weird [ __ ] in a
sweatshirt
he's talking about arsenio hall though
he was like bro uh i mean he's not crack
he was like i'm not crazy in all that so
he talked about it but again he was like
yo just think about it i'm making all
that money and i'll hallucinate
because i don't know but he's basically
saying he just well dave dave chappelle
backed him too
yeah same way just saying like he goes
he goes he's not crazy
he goes he goes he said maybe hollywood
is maybe
probably yeah that's what he said you
know what i mean like i guess like
i don't know i don't know i know yeah
behind those scenes most people just
don't know
like what they're dealing with i mean
there's a there's probably a lot of
pressure like
you know being a stand-up community then
all of a sudden you're a big movie star
and like
it's just a different pressure like
where it's like we don't we do
podcasting like we don't necessarily
have to deal with
you know the thing in the world and it's
a gross business full of sociopaths and
[ __ ] vultures it's gross
that's what i'm saying they make you do
gross [ __ ] and horrible [ __ ] and it's
and so like
it's probably what he was desperate it's
like probably what he was feeling yeah
you know yeah you can't handle it
yeah yeah it makes you kind of sacrifice
who you are you know to like
it's when you're trying to appeal to
everyone it's like yeah who am i you
start to go like
like jim carrey talks do you see him jim
carry acts now he's crazy he's not worth
it
yeah but it's probably like that wears
on you after a while when you're like
there's [ __ ]
millions and millions of dollars riding
on who wants that don't say this
be this way do this yeah do this
children's movie yeah
you know you can't be seen doing
anything adult or anything because it
it compromised your whole thing who
wants that no it's just
so much pressure yeah i don't think it's
the pressure it's like you're almost
selling out
yeah that's just selling out yeah
because they're making big boy money
big big ones yeah yeah and then you
probably get to like 50 or 60 and you
see
how much it is and how much you had to
sacrifice and you go like dude i'm only
going to be here for a couple more
decades was it worth it
so how many [ __ ] times can i be on a
jet yeah but you also have 200 million
in the bank
yeah that takes you to monaco you know
what i'm saying yeah
i mean i just want to go to moderation
like you're in bellaire like was it
worth it yeah
like yeah like i get martin lawrence
like crazy
dude you made so much [ __ ] money yeah
but why don't these people go to monaco
they always like hang out in la i would
go to the f1 driver
roger federer no you hang out with danny
ricardo my boy lives in monaco
yeah but and it's like a small area but
it's like the richest of the rich
live there yeah so like you pull out a
fryer was like oh my god
you know like you gotta have a bugatti
oh you gotta have something because
everything out there is ridiculous you
gotta have like
just to live there you have to send them
your tax returns you have to have a
certain amount like 20 25 million
bank it's not it's a nut spot danny
ricardo says like the best place on
earth yeah yeah
yeah i always where's monaco located
it's in europe somewhere
yeah i'm i've never even made enough
money to even know where it is
monaco monaco like when you see it you
know like oh this is where roger federer
meets up with
you know the prince of whatever and they
[ __ ] so it's only it's it's only 499
acres
it's in italy yeah 3 000 people live
there take it can you pull up a picture
of the
port though the boats it's so crazy
let me see i mean we should do a live
podcast at my house
now seven people would come but let's
charge a thousand dollars to take it oh
yeah that would be like wow
they're like oh that's so beautiful yeah
oh my so you know how much the f1
drivers make so lewis hamilton who's the
number one
in the world i think dan ricardo's
better has a uh inferior car and still
that's because but whatever so lewis
hamilton lives on the penthouse
dan ricardo lives underneath him there's
like this there's this
like [ __ ] residential area there
where it's like the you know roger
federer and lewis hamilton
it's just like that's is that where they
feeling focus with will smith
oh i don't know i've never seen that
movie and we'll never see it but uh
that's what the that's what margaret
we love margaritaville we do love
margaret yeah i absolutely love will
smith the movie
i don't want to see that movie that
movie was okay all right well it was
okay
yeah and as soon as i get a couple mail
i'm going to monica
you need more than a couple papa i know
i know
couple mill's not a lot anymore couple
mill gets you a [ __ ] place in
riverside you know yeah yeah that's what
i run away too riverside
we were saying that's just great yeah
that's why i'm scared about this tax
hike in new york and
california no well california we're
staying the same right now i mean we're
gonna copy you probably but
i think hopefully what happens for those
who don't know so new york's gonna be
the highest tax state
in all the land but what's gonna happen
is all the tech and all the smart
business people
they're like [ __ ] this because anyone
who makes over 5 million it's like 54
of your income goes to federal and state
taxes so 54
so then they're gonna leave go to
florida new york's gonna be
[ __ ] yeah no business gonna be there
and it's gonna be a [ __ ] show because
there should be no money for the economy
it's better so why the [ __ ] would they
do that then because they need money
because they because they shut down
everybody and also all the riots
billions of dollars in damages
like they just need money so that's why
they legalize that
they legalize that exactly but what's
[ __ ] hypocritical is that that's
crazy so he puts so many people away
from marijuana yeah because they know
that's gonna make money that's weird
ain't that but but what's gonna happen
is
not as bad as alcohol not even close no
not even close but what i hope happens
is california sees that new york becomes
this total [ __ ] show and like oh that
ain't the move and then they don't do it
here
yeah but you're that's you know fingers
crossed oh i know because i think
they're
the legislators gearing up for that here
yeah i'm sure
i'm sure yeah yeah what do you do how
can i completely [ __ ]
california yeah it's a 14 tax i believe
on anyone making combined
for a million a million yeah which is in
new york that's a lot of people
yeah in la it's a ton of people it's a
ton of people
well in california it's so many people
yeah california i can't afford that
it's 65 of my income well the thing is
they can't afford it was like how much
are you going to put up with like what's
it worth you to live in california
is it worth 600 000 a year out of your
dude they can't afford it a million in
in in new york or la it's not it doesn't
go far it doesn't go far
you're still paying tackle and then this
is just more taxes 65 percent
a majority of goes i mean
i'm telling you dude the progressive
wing of the democratic party is in for a
rude awakening
when they get a little lesson on what
human nature is all about oh dude how
self-interested people are
because the exodus has already started
oh yeah i mean austin is like
daily people are moving daily yeah i
mean florida miami booming
you talk to realtors down there like
dude we can't arizona we're talking to
developers to develop more
vegas they don't have enough houses yeah
because people and especially now that
the economy is digital and you can work
from anywhere correct
commercial real estate is going to
collapse and people are going like hey
man i'm just going to live in
texas where there's no state tax and
i'll just go to new york when i have a
meeting or i'll zoom it
i'll assume that [ __ ] and it's like the
tax base is going to flee have you
thought about leaving
yeah i'm going to texas are you really
yeah have to talk to your wife
yeah i'm going to start no i i've you
know he's done 17 podcasts i'm sure yeah
yeah so i'm going to do start out by
splitting time there and then slowly
just yeah
and you're going to move to austin yeah
i'm sorry i said uh get off rogan's nuts
earlier no that's fine i'm
i'm on it i mean i go over there yeah
the way he caught him
i want to kick somebody in the chest i
just go there i go like that he kicks me
in the chest whatever he wants to do
barbecue wheelchair wheel kick to the
chest yeah i'll just come over take a
shot to the chest guy he got forced with
that guy now there's something there man
i think more than mary i'm sure more
people are going to keep going
especially if that tax
thing hits here that's rough that's
rough super [ __ ] rough
i'm still i'm still holding i'm still
holding it down man yeah well you're
going to choke out la
yeah la's yours dude yep i'll be the
only one left yeah
but until that tax rate until until you
get that bugatti payment comes and you
go you know what maybe i'll just go down
to austin
i know have a little yeah i know man
yeah it's bad it's gonna be bad man
it's a lot of money dude i know it's a
lot when you start doing the math
like i don't have to worry about that
i'm not making that type of money yet
but if i was i mean i it would be a
consideration right away i talk about
with my best guys once a month
yeah once a month stressing me out it's
tough
paying taxes is like i think if everyone
knew where the taxes were going people
would be a lot
exactly yeah even then i'm not thrilled
about like you what in
what [ __ ] lane do you come from where
you think it's okay to take half of my
[ __ ] man
because i figured out a way to make
money you take half money well if you
take and have my [ __ ] i want to know
that my daughter's going to and [ __ ]
amazing public schools [ __ ] out here
roads are [ __ ] dope
homelessness yeah education [ __ ]
homelessness taking care like everything
is dope people are like everything's on
fire
yeah but then you see these uh the
[ __ ] pentagon budget is 85
of the tax budget [ __ ] israel's
getting this saudi arabia is getting
this
you're going what the [ __ ] dude i don't
want to pay for that no i don't want to
pay for our military industrial complex
which is really uh you know the real
[ __ ] problem with this country
since eisenhower admitted it you know oh
wow yeah
it's like on his exit on his if you
watch
president eisenhower's like last speech
he's like we got to be careful this
military industrial companies that's all
they're just redundant weapons and then
they go and bomb to make more weapons
and
they use the taxpayer dollars like an
infinite bank where they just keep
funding weapons makers and it's brutal
it's brutal that's where the majority of
our taxes go to the pentagon i mean dude
nobody can [ __ ] with us we have you know
we got the brendan shop of weapons dude
heavyweight [ __ ] knockout power
oh yeah no one [ __ ] with this yeah
nobody can [ __ ] which is cool yeah
but so we get a last you know can we
just be kind of
good do we have to be great can you get
a list down so you take all my money to
pay for it
we don't need do you need all those
bazookas yeah we don't need any more we
also it's not fought like that anymore
it's like porn we have we have enough
yeah we don't need new porn stuff i can
barely handle it yeah there's enough of
it dude yeah
i mean there's like years and years of
porn i don't need any new no i'm good
yeah yeah i gotta get the ones i like
too much dude i'm trying to adventure
into things like
you're watching yeah yeah yeah porn goes
back a long time
yeah i don't like doing it i've been
going through a vintage phase recently
i've been [ __ ] watching i can't get
off the ambulance my wife doesn't watch
it so i've been unbelievable amber
was my favorite when i was a kid bring
her up into it yeah
this is when they were stars when you
would have relationships
in your brain yeah porn stars like i
would only jerk off to her she was my
girl
you'd feel bad if you switched i didn't
i was loyal yeah
christie canyon had nice [ __ ] bombs
too
yeah she would this is an original porn
star i think i've seen her
yeah i've never seen her see if you can
recognize the oh geez
she said see if you recognize her from
the place maybe you could recognize
images
i have to see her work
just to confirm i i'm such a visual
learner
amber lynn oh anal
you have to see video just yeah okay
i've seen her before you have
yep that thing oh no that's not her no
that's not her you can if maybe
that's her but that she's had work done
she was such a beautiful she's a cougar
now huh
she's a cook when she was young she
hadn't she's still doing the she's still
putting up videos and [ __ ]
that's her right there
yeah that's why i can't get down with
the old ones they're just hairy
yeah i don't like that hair no i grilled
your hair my hair uh
i'm older than you guys when i grew up
all girls had hair
it was like before girls did brazilian
waxing so when you when you went down in
a girl you just
there's a lot of fumes man fumes get
caught and they get caught in the butt
that's where they get caught yeah that
script landed
there's a landing strip it wasn't no
there was not even street there's no
strip no
it was just full on books
my mouth would be on your head
you didn't even see the [ __ ] you just
were licking hair i didn't know what a
[ __ ] looked like till the 90s
look i didn't see one it was just like a
hair like a mod chupacabra you just
like you were putting it in the [ __ ]
hair monster you're licking them with
your fingers in a muffin's mouth like
that
he's all trying to push it to the side
yeah i didn't know where the [ __ ] i
didn't know what it looked like dude
first [ __ ] i just grabbed it like that
did you put two pigtails i don't even
think i was licking put that or just
lick the hair
oh it's like a dog look at himself
i didn't even know what [ __ ] looked
like yeah they had philly
anderson has a pretty [ __ ] yeah really
one of the prettiest
yeah t-rex pretty [ __ ] you know what
t-rex what's that it's a movie she did
oh but did you see the
bob why are you saying bob wire as well
you don't see her [ __ ] in that no but
i'm saying that's like
barbie but you've never seen her she's
not nude in those
yeah i've seen it yeah tommy tommy lee
sexy
i've never seen that you never see where
he honks the boat's horn with his dick
he got he got a piece he's got a piece
greek too
yeah oh great kid yeah i know look at
that
it's like [ __ ] irish watching conor
mcgregor
he does have a big dick on him oh he
doesn't have you've never seen that he's
got no i've never seen him
he's like one more glue gun yeah that's
like the oh that is
always like the first hilton kind of
days he was the before that first one
before they were
the first one yeah and when they're
[ __ ] oh love her do you have you ever
seen it love her oh love her i love her
oh yeah i love her they were in love
yeah she probably love her the whole
time
but her [ __ ] i'm sorry oh no you're
fine
have you seen it it's pretty i'm just
saying i haven't seen a person like it
should be in a museum i'm not talking
like
smutty i'm talking like it's gorgeous
also i work here so
you guys yeah you sign an nda where yeah
you got it i mean there's like no
meat coming out it's just like a hoof
a nice hug feel so pretty it's like
you're getting stuff yeah it's a
hufflepuff yeah now i'm curious can we
just take
a peek
[Laughter]
off when you see it you're gonna be like
yo dude this is the michelangelo of puss
it's that beautiful man she's still
banging i think she got married recently
she did yeah i think so she's canadian
right out china
so it was either you're either a comrade
electro fan or pamela anderson you're
pamela
clearly i love connor i was i was karma
election
how pretty that's like a heart yeah look
at that yeah
solid yeah she's banging tidy yeah she's
banging that's photoshop
yeah she was in good burgers good burger
you don't know good
girl oh my bad welcome to good
a lot of stuff but uh she recently i've
met her in person she got into she had
my sister car when she was parked by the
uh
cheesecake factory and she heard my
little niece scream and she was
trying to hit a run and she everybody
scream in the back seat she literally
drove around the corner
and she was like oh my god i'm so sorry
and all that she gave her uh wait a
second
she tried to hit your knee hit no no no
no no no hitting the run yeah on the car
yeah carmen let you hit a car and then
was going to run away
yeah the car that she hit was my
sister's car my sister was she worked in
a cheesecake
cheese steak cat what is it called
cheesecake cheesecake factory
and beverly hills and beverly hills
cheesesteak factory
pretty good name too yeah that's not a
good idea really and she uh
she hit my sister's car while i was
parked oh damn then she was gonna take
off she took off and she heard my niece
scream
and she was your niece injured no she's
not at least she's just open so
everything's okay yeah everything was
okay but
i saw her i was like i'm so pretty right
so beautiful hit me
i was like well girl it's just a santro
yeah so wow carmen alexa tried to get
away with uh
hitting your car seriously yeah yeah
that's that's a weird story yeah she
paid for it
what do you mean yeah she did she
apologizes she and everything she was
super nice
did she run back apologizing like yeah
no she had on a green uh
like an olive dress oh yeah is this the
dave navarro days when she was with dave
navarro i don't know
how long ago was this this was in 2012
eleven something like that yeah that's a
hot second ago yeah yeah
wait a minute she's by herself by
herself in the car she was in a uh
she was on a bmw a brand new one but not
like a station wagon it was like a
four-door did she damage the car
i was just like i'm just asking details
to see if you're lying i just wanted to
catch it
bmw i mean it was an audi no it was that
night come on not the station wagon
i don't have branded sneakers i probably
[ __ ] okay
i got it yeah she's so bad yeah green
dress i'll never forget it
now what acting school did she go to uh
scott's
uh why is she really good at acting i
mean for me it's meryl streep
karma you think you think mayor streep
can't
i'm joking oh he's joking i was joking
yeah damn do you like natural are you
okay with
i'm okay with everything hot's hot real
it doesn't freak you out stuff like when
they're bending over and like you see
the bag
what what bag that's kind of hot you can
see it you can see this
like the ripples yeah i'm all for it i
can't see that but no when
when like a girl's bending over and
she's got fakes and like gravity takes
the
oh the titties you see the ripples on
the side of the
the silicone bag oh no i didn't you've
never seen that but now those are you
talking about old tits
because the new ones really don't do
that yeah they kind of just stay there
yeah yeah i've never seen that yeah she
is
old tips would do that hanging doggy
yeah and she don't have a little tip she
has it she has a new one right
that's her right now she looks like a
totally different but you can't see that
that's something's wrong with that
filter
yeah yeah it's a filter it's a filter
for sure i think yeah i don't
who this [ __ ] looks gorgeous she looks
she does i wouldn't
say it doesn't look like the carbon
electric that i wouldn't know that was
didn't she pause for playboy
years ago oh yeah i think that's just
she got her start right
she used to tackle dennis rodman's bit
dick oh man you heard that
story oh yeah the michael jordan store
yeah i don't know where he broke his
broke his dick yeah last dance baby dave
navarro too man
all right let's do some kernel bags
yeah she was in last dance yeah she was
talking about that yeah
they had her in last name yeah yeah okay
this is just a little follow up from
the miz coming on to our show he
actually ended up losing that tag team
match at wrestlemania and
bad bunny actually came out and killed
it
he looks like he is better than some of
the professional wrestlers side to wwe
yeah so these are just some clips
[Applause]
i wish you the flips oh
[Applause]
he's good yeah
i think he is doing something where he
has like a short-term contract
with wwe he's doing a little more than
what uh logan paul is doing logan paul
seems more of a like
reoccurring character whereas bad bunny
is somebody who's like
a character and then he actually does
the matches so i think he's
starting to dabble in like wwe and
professional wrestling has a side
career why not who do you guys got jake
or ben
i got ben you think about it no not
jacob jacob i think jake
well you just said ben well yeah i
thought about it and i'm
i'm hearing things in wildcard i talked
to him the other day
uh been looking slow so i got i got jake
so philly show
right is that what they call it the
philly yeah yeah frasier
who do you got i i i i it's a tough one
i don't know because i don't know enough
about like
obviously if it was uh if ben could
touch him it would be over so i don't
know but
is jake a good box he knocked out nate
robinson which doesn't mean much but
looking at ben's footage i mean jake's
fudge he looks pretty [ __ ] good he
does and also ben just had surgery right
of
hip surgery and he was at like doesn't
want to fight anymore so it's kind of a
money play
yeah the more i talk about the more i
lean with jake
yeah but if he goes past three rounds
should get interesting
if jay can't knock him out and ben can
somehow weather that storm after three
it's
all been yeah because ben is tough too
he's tough and he takes beatings
he's taking beatings until he gets his
hands on you and just chokes you out
like snake
i want i'm curious about jake's
conditioning like you know that's what
i'm saying after
three let's see what happens that's why
i was like teetering like i don't know
who but i'm hearing
you know ben is a little slow yeah
i'm just excited for that mosby doll oh
rematch in that fight yeah
that fight that's the go that's the best
fight i think it's a good fight in mma
oh yeah yeah because that first fight
was a good fight mm-hmm
it wasn't a bad [ __ ] it was a good fight
i mean it was close i thought
you don't think mazda got him on the on
you don't think i was at the bottom
he had to cut weight he didn't have a
full training camp yeah i mean
strikes look good dude i've seen some
compilations where he's been such a
beast dude
he's tough tough as they come he was
talking but he also got rocked by that
dude um who fought
uh he got rocked a little bit gilbert
burns yeah he rocked him at the
beginning yeah
i'm sorry we'll see mosfet has a great
striker tough
tough tough tough that's a good division
with colby covington
yeah the best that's great i'm sorry i
know it's a different show
okay so we've talked about michael b
jordan quite a bit on the show
and we all have differing opinions on
how attractive he is
i wanted you guys to give him an updated
rating in this purple shirt
he looks small how do you feel about it
is he still in la 10 me to me he is
i know i'm new to still la-10 but uh
somebody said laurie not feeding him in
his shows
[Laughter]
he looks like he looks like he's a
little sugar in his tank yeah yeah yeah
he looks like he's all the [ __ ] it could
be for a roll though la 10.
still in la 10 a little different la 10
what what's a different l18 uh west
hollywood 10.
which in my opinion might be a little
higher than a general ly10 oh wait
higher
west hollywood ten you gotta be fine as
[ __ ] to be a tennis are you calling him
finer than what he is in that shirt
in west hollywood he's killing it in
that shirt absolutely
okay all right well ellie's here all
right i like it is that you think that's
like a body suit that snaps underneath
oh yeah like a like one of those uh you
take them out right when you need to go
pee and then you snap them back on like
it's weird because his head's so big
it's not a turtleneck's not my hand it's
just a weird angle i guess
it's too good i bet he i bet he is shred
city
yeah i'm going with angles i think it's
just a weird angle do you think it's
weird it just looks weird
down the shirt
okay all right okay
uh have you seen the usps uh hell yeah
design for the air force ones
so uh usps is actually filing a lawsuit
against nike
for using their uh patent design
without getting any sort of permission
god i want to get my hands on them now
then
okay and people are calling uh nike
hypocrites for
doing something like this when they
didn't let a little nausea
interesting yeah why they they censored
those little nas x yeah because they
didn't make those and they made these
but then you're gonna
shut down the little nas collab yeah i
was like dude you already made the devil
sneakers
nike they're called nikes
damn those those slave labor made right
hard brandon i don't know it's gonna be
tough to get now no yeah those are hard
those are so sick come on get those take
them on the road dude see what you see
how long
that's going to stick over here
like those baby monitor cameras yeah let
them know just hide them and then invite
them in the room you see
these dudes sneaking around at night
like wait
little nasdaq does he get to keep his
money that he made off that no
no he i don't think so he don't damn
well he might but he probably got a
percentage of it
because that doesn't have anything to do
with him he was like but he's i'm just
the face of it
oh he's not in the livestream he signed
up
the company has to deal with that yeah
oh yeah oh so he won yeah he won he got
his money
but i want those though yeah yeah those
are hard
i i to me that souls were always a
little i liked it when i was younger but
do you feel like they are like old man
shoes a little bit with the souls they
can be they're a little thick
yeah you wearing the wrong pants they
look weird but i love air force ones
they're so comfy yeah i got some more
now
they're comfortable yeah they're kind of
they're the most comfy shoes yeah thank
you mate
i don't know the ones yeah you got the
95s though
yeah yeah there's a comfy what else you
got jen
all right it's your guy jordan ones are
like the most bro come on talk that talk
see i think dunk's the most uncomfy yeah
i don't mind jordan once it's
done if i walk around in dunks all day
my [ __ ] feet hurt yeah just like
stiff skateboard flat shoes
yeah certainly our dunks are kind of
like comfortable though certainly
yeah i got you okay so this is chet
hanks he
is coming out for a while boys summer
he got a song yeah he has a new type of
sound
now for white boys it's gonna be the
white boy summer anthem this right here
yes
okay he made it hot boy white boy summer
got your favorite instagram
hit the strip club by mike thunder she
let me beat it i'm the white boy wonder
hot boy oh my god
is here he made that song in three hours
i mean the white person happened like
two days ago yeah he's got
merch out he's got he got up dude can
you imagine tom hanks seeing this
well why are you doing this hey he's got
his own leg is he like chet why are you
doing this
you know i'm force gump for [ __ ] sakes
dude
see i kind of like it dude because look
colin has i'm a fan
colin hanks looks like tom hanks yeah
never will live up to his pops no but he
but he's a
good actor he's a good actor yeah but
like for this era i mean
he's popping chad hanks is doing it he's
more famous than this yeah i mean he's
working out he's like because now you're
like
your job description is like a hundred
things yeah like jake paul's like i'm a
merch dropper yeah
i'm a youtuber i'm a boxer i'm a chinese
spy
you know it's like all of them yeah yeah
and like this dude's doing that he's
like a bad
music guy uh personality uh
instagram instagram all that [ __ ] yeah
inspirational quotes
yeah he's doing it he does the
rastafarian thing yeah that was
funny but he's best yeah he was talking
in patois
yeah that's how he got famous dude oh
really
he's perfect i'm just starting to learn
i'm just starting to learn about dude
he's like it's controversy he causes
controversy what's hey what's that
with the upper right one what's it
what's he doing there that's him filming
speech probably talking got
[Music]
my dad's house i
don't want to watch big with my dad who
is this guy who
i i love this who wants to watch captain
phillips with my dad
oh what's up y'all want to come see the
real wilson ball i'm not in my room
wait find this video i don't want to
jump on that big [ __ ] piano
who wants to know this afternoon he
usually in the car channel when he talks
do the white man wiggle one all the way
up dude he's fantastic
yeah i call this dance a white man
wiggle we just follow the ball and let
the girl go yeah
wait white man yeah no not this one
working out
you go all the way to the top white man
wiggle yeah the white this is my one of
my favorite ones oh i saw that one in
the middle
oh you just stay there and let her work
oh yeah
some girls throw it on you now she's
slow wandering oh man
your chat hanks is [ __ ]
let him live his life man yeah another
another little fact he's greek
rita wilson is greek tom hanks converted
to greek orthodox oh that's right yeah
god he's [ __ ] great he's great man
just creates content man
isn't right that yeah this is where it
went super viral
big up the whole island
coming from now that's that's at the
golden clothes
[Laughter]
god
make the king
oh yeah
yeah i just picture his dad watches me
like
i wonder what his dad's next dad got
covet
his dad's all done with some real [ __ ]
[Music]
tell adele adele you know i sent me a
priya for a long time
and uh
do you think he just has an endless
supply of money from his dad yes where
his dad's just like yeah
whatever dude just keep making [ __ ]
stuff yeah for his merch he was like dad
hear me out white boy summer just give
me 10 grand
his dad's riding on the phone like hold
up yeah no yeah no forrest gump
yeah okay what what are you saying yeah
hear me out before white boy
dad it's [ __ ] everywhere dude it's
fine but
don't do that when he gets around his
boys he's like you hurt yeah yeah i mean
then he goes to his dad
dad listen dad listen listen to me it's
all over right now
i found my thing i found my thing my
[ __ ] thing he's like
are you still doing you're making that
thing and i'm doing it
yeah remember how like forever i was
like lost not anymore
let me out here it's a white summer
his dad's all just universal students
you're not doing the jamaican thing
whatever yeah
yeah i mean everyone's talking about the
white boy's summer the black he does
black white boys summer black queen
summer
and he's got he's got oh he's oh yeah
yeah look at him going now it's a fake
boy summer but
whatever let me ask you guys where where
were you when you found out what
boom bye bye and about the boy's head
meant
do you know what that was about them and
how and how long did you dance to that
without knowing
i don't know what it means it's it's
horrible
what's it mean i mean we could google it
before you see
that song boom bye bye boy's head
rude boy no promote them nasty man to
mafi something like that i
can't cut off someone's head it's worse
than that
what uh
this was like the biggest song in the
90s this song was like
everywhere you would go this song but no
one knew the lyrics nobody knew what it
meant so everyone was dancing to it and
the chorus
is means one of the worst things how do
we search it
like that
let me see if that you're close to it
right there yeah that's it
yeah you guys will know the song when
you hear it
did they play this in belly world is in
some
chat hang on make this song
when you go translate these lyrics but
translate it yeah
you gotta translate i can't say it
you're talking about
it's that bad it's that and the funny
thing is people used to i mean people
were just [ __ ]
yeah translation yeah
and then maybe we could just read it
okay yeah
world is in trouble anytime wait wait
for oh
here's english world is in trouble in
time as you come batty boy all right
it's like boom bye bye in a body boy
rude boy no promote nasty man
okay that's not helping the bottom right
here
no this is this is difficult i think you
think you got a chance okay i just
should i just tell you what yeah
he's like yeah i'm saying it's horrible
so uh batu boy
is uh means a gay guy oh capital gay
yeah i see that yeah boom bye bye and
about the boy's head means killing the
game shoot a gay guy in the head
i don't promote their nasty lifestyle i
want them all dead oh wow yeah yeah and
then the other lyrics are worse about
oozies using oozies to kill them
jesus so nobody knew what these lyrics
were for
years boomed about four years so they
say prosecute homosexuals and
shoot another one yeah you know what's
funny when he said
this stuff it was a big controversy and
and i was going like
did you not listen to boom bye bye he
made a song about it
this is actually mild compared to the
song well he was talking about elton
john
george michael yeah he's not a
progressive thinker
he's a little small-minded yeah but this
is on a big record label too huh yeah
the funny thing is dude that song used
to
be yeah i mean even gay guys were in
there going like boom
because nobody knew what it meant they
put it in movies though yeah dude
it was a massive hit yeah and it's funny
because nobody
back then like nobody even wanted to
know what it meant after what it meant
like because they kind of just let it go
like yeah when you hear a dope beat you
you you know you hear it up yeah that is
terrible so terrible and that was just
kind of the error too like i remember
one of my favorite albums was um
ice cube american nightmare
uh maybe america's most wanted what's
the one we had that song white devil
that song was a great song
and i used to bump to white babies no no
i think it was on white devils
it might have been america's most wanted
i think it's on america's most wanted
yeah white devil that was a good song
and is it about killing white people no
it wasn't
white people death certificate
great album by the way underrated album
that was that i was thinking of predator
i'm thinking of predator my bad
but that was the era where you just you
sang lyrics that were about but you
didn't know what they're saying well you
kind of did kind of didn't but like yeah
well you didn't care
you didn't you took it for what it was
yeah yeah it's a dumb song even eminem
was dark too
we listen to eminem yeah he hugged out
john and he got forgiven for
yeah he's got everything dude anything
else chin you want anymore you're good i
think that's good all right
all right we're in naples florida this
weekend thursday friday saturday naples
come get some the 15th to the 17th
naples florida in austin texas we're
adding shows we'll add a late thursday
show
rest of the shows are low on tickets so
april 22nd through april 24th
that's next thursday friday saturday
austin texas
and then houston texas may 20 through
the 22nd was just added
so come get some houston but this week
naples next week austin tickets at f a t
k
z dot com what do you got chappelle and
then uh may 6 through the 8th i'll be at
philly helium
comedy club and then also the following
weekend may 13th through the 15th
i'll be in raleigh north carolina at
good night's comedy club
tickets chapelle lacey.com and love it
giannis oh you're in austin next week
with us yeah i'm in austin from the
20th uh 20th to the 25th doing shows
just google it check my website
um tampa um atlantic city celebrity
theater
and listen to my podcast my new podcast
long days so check it out
love it man love it y'all honest we love
you man i love you guys thanks for
having me it's always fun
i was wondering like 1am i just thought
it was cold that's crazy i was more than
wondering
it's crazy though uh yes speaking of
cold i always associate
uh cold with uh the color blue and so
that's why i got these university
blues on you see what i did there that
connection
oh i see what you can do don't tell them
don't tell them
[Laughter]
we just beat the nets without you know
evr superstars and i got the off-white
shout out to virgin
horses so close that's not a seven game
series so what you mean
it's easy one there's one there's one
game rolling boy
[Applause]
darth vader's for your ass
it's not that's not how it's not
whatever he says
okay that's it maples this week thursday
friday saturday